[Music]
let's consider a bar magnet its shape is
similar to that of a chocolate bar it
has two ends on the opposite sides where
n and s are written do the ends have any
significance these two ends are called
the poles of a magnet the one where n is
written is not Pole and where s is
written is South Pole from the last
video we now know that there is an
invisible magnetic field surrounding it
and if you place any magnetic material
in this field then it will be attracted
towards the magnet but this field is
invisible to us however there is one way
in which we can visualize it how tie up
this magnet with a piece of paper with
the help of a sellotape keep it on the
table and turn it upside down so that
the magnet is on the lower face of the
paper the magnet is between the paper
and the surface of the table mark the
position of two poles of a magnet on the
upper face this place is above the North
Pole and this one is above the South
Pole finally sprinkle some iron filings
on the upper face slowly so as to cover
the entire area surrounding the magnet
what will be notice we will find that
the iron filings arrange themselves in a
specific pattern this pattern not only
shows us the pattern but also tells us a
lot about the strength of the magnetic
field of a bar magnet
first of all iron filings are nothing
but very tiny pieces of iron which is a
ferromagnetic material so they are
attracted by a magnet you will see that
more iron filings are gathered at the
two specific locations and less
elsewhere these two other locations
directly above the two poles of a magnet
so the iron filings are attracted more
towards the poles of a magnet than the
center but what does this tell us about
the strength of a magnetic field more
iron attracted at the poles means that
the field at the poles is stronger and
consequently the
it is weaker at the center not only a
bar magnet every magnet has a different
field pattern this field pattern depends
on the shape of a magnet yes different
shaped magnets have different field
patterns for instance here is the field
pattern of a horseshoe magnet you can
see that more iron filings are gathered
around the two poles while less so
elsewhere in the next video we will see
different types of magnets see there
[Music]